une foule immense pour les obsèques de
jean paul ii une messe célébrée sur le
parvis de la basilique devant plusieurs
centaines de personnalités du monde
entier
un hommage planétaire et la ferveur des
pèlerins polonais qui réclame la
canonisation immédiate d'un événement
qui globalement se dérouler sans heurts
au caire l'attentât hier dans la vieille
ville a été revendiqué par un groupe
islamiste inconnue un américain une
française sont décédés c'est la première
fois depuis sept ans que les accidents
tous ont pris pour cible en egypte
la violence routière avec ce mauvais
chiffres pour le mois de mars le nombre
de morts sur les routes a augmenté de 8
5% entre aux la vitesse malgré
l'installation massive des radars
automatiques
depuis les derniers préparatifs du
mariage de charles et de camilla la
météo prévoit un temps de chien le
royaume semble peu enthousiaste pour ces
noces auquel n'assisteront que quelques
personnalités et puis la foire du trône
en ce moment et pendant deux mois 2000
fort à 350 attractions et 5 millions de
visiteurs des manèges de plus en plus
fou pour des amateurs de sensations
fortes
voilà monsieur bonsoir le pop jean paul
ii a été inhumé dans de simples cercueil
à même la terre dans la crypte de
suivant ses dernières volontés
auparavant devant plusieurs centaines de
dirigeants venus du monde entier une
foule de fidèles se sont déroulées ces
obsèques célébrées sur le parvis de la
basilique saint-pierre la messe aura
duré près de trois heures une messe
célébrée par le doyen du collège des
cardinaux et qui s'est achevée sous les
applaudissements gérard griesbeck de
ghannouch
moment incroyable à la fin de la messe
le cercueil et porté vers la basilique
saint pierre
les cloches sonnent à toute volée et la
clameur de la foule couvre tous les
dizaines de milliers de jeunes massés
sur la place applaudissent à tout rompre
quand le nom de jean paul ii comme avant
d'ailleurs beaucoup guette les fenêtres
du pape comme si un miracle pouvait
encore se produire
ce décalage entre la force de volonté
exprimée par les fidèles et la réserve
des cardinaux et des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement a marqué toute la cérémonie
la messe a duré trois longues heures
qu'on tue et de chants et de prières
dans son homélie le cardinal allemand
joseph ratzinger a rappelé la lutte
menée par jean paul 2 contre le nazisme
puis le communisme sur la place
saint-pierre le vent qui s'est levé fait
tourner les pages du livre des évangiles
posé sur le cercueil
à ce moment de la cérémonie sont sans
doute deux cent à trois cent mille
pèlerins aux abords de la place saint
pierre des polonais en grand nombre bien
sûr et dans la foule beaucoup d'émotion
et des banderoles qui réclament la
canonisation immédiate de jean paul ii
alors le cercueil du pape est emporté
loin des caméras
le vatican vient de diffuser des photos
de la mise en bière avant la messe et de
l'enterrement dans la crypte de la
basilique sur la place
la cérémonie est terminée mais beaucoup
de fidèles ne bouge pas se refusant sans
doute à tourner la page et le match des
grands de la planète qui avait tenu à
faire le déplacement la plupart des
chefs d'état étaient arrivés dès hier à
rome des présidents américains placé à
côté de jacques chirac et de son épouse
de tony blair au roi de jordanie du
président iranien au roi d'espagne au
prince charles et pour la première fois
le président de l'état hébreu a serré la
main de bachar al assad
le numéro un syrien loïc de la mornais
15e rois reines princes et grands ducs
44 présidents 25 premier ministre et 120
autres hommes politiques et des
dignitaires religieux non catholiques
au total environ 200 personnalités ont
assisté aux obsèques de jean paul ii
sous les objectifs de milliers de
journalistes
bien sûr il ya les officiels attendus
comme jacques et bernadette chirac ou
encore george bush et son prédécesseur
bill clinton
mais ces funérailles furent surtout
placée sous le signe de l'universalité
jean paul ii avait tendu la main vers
les autres religions alors ils sont
venus nombreux des patriarches
orthodoxes aux grands rabbins d'israël
en passant par les représentants du
qatar ou des émirats arabes unis et le
temps de ses obsèques
jean paul ii semble avoir comme
rapprocher de force les frères ennemis
autour d'une table diplomatique le
président syrien bachar el-assad serre
la main aux voisins a dit le président
israélien moshé katzav
et le président iranien mohammad khatami
côtoient fraîchement le président
américain
inde georges bush qui au passage laisse
attendre pantois jacques chirac et sa
poignée de main
aujourd'hui le prince charles aurait dû
assister à un mariage le sien ce sera
donc un enterrement
il a reporté à demain ses noces avec
camilla mais a malencontreusement serrer
la main du président zimbabwéen mugabe
en froid notoire avec le gouvernement
britannique
son geste fait déjà scandale à londres
bref les enterrements c'est comme les
mariages
on sourit poliment en retrouvant la
famille on arrange les petites affaires
et on sauvegarde les apparences rome
portant des drapeaux blanc et rouge des
dizaines de milliers de polonais ont
vécu dans une émotion plus vive encore
l'adieu à leur pape sur la place saint
pierre
c'est eux qui en réclamait la fin des
obsèques de jean paul ii soit
immédiatement canonisé reportage maryse
burgot franck blessés le cercueil de
jean paul ii keeps la place saint pierre
sous les applaudissements élus de
milliers de polonais devant la basilique
une marée de drapeaux rouge et blanc les
couleurs de la pologne
les habitants de wadowice est la ville
natale de jean paul ii ont dormi sur
place pour être sûr d'assister aux
funérailles devant l'invasion
pour nous les polonais jean paul ii
était comme un père
il fallait vraiment que nous venions ici
un rom pour lui dire adieu dit cette
femme depuis 11 heures du soir nous
attendions debout maintenant nous
pouvons enfin prié 17 hommes de wadowice
et concentrer les compatriotes de karol
wojtyla écoute à la radio les traduction
en polonais de la messe ils vivent en
fait leur dernière occasion de remercier
jean paul ii de les avoir délivré de la
domination soviétique
nous les citoyens devaient forcément
vivre cet événement ensemble mais en
fait vous n'auriez pas eu des
montagnards habillé comme moi je les ai
perdus dans la foule bien après la fin
des funérailles ceux de wadowice et
comme beaucoup d'autres polonais restent
sur la place
c'est tellement difficile de partir
qu'ils entonnent le chant polonais
préférés de jean paul ii sous les
fenêtres de ce qui était encore il ya
quelques jours ses appartements
demain les habitants de vado lité
rejoignent la pologne 27 heures de bus
cela donne beaucoup de temps pour se
refaire le film de teaser d'inoubliable
et ce vendredi en pologne a été décrété
jour férié les entreprises écoles les
commerces étaient fermés les rues
désertes des centaines de milliers de
fidèles de compatriotes du pack ont
suivi sur écran géant les obsèques comme
à cracovie
la communion dans la douleur de tout un
peuple ce soir à l'heure précise où est
mort jean paul ii les polonais sont
appelés à éteindre toutes les lumières
pendant cinq minutes
amaury guibert christian galley merci
dit la banderole comme pour résumer la
pensée de chacun d'entre eux ils sont
800 milles de cracovie et des villes
alentour
réunis sur la peine de blogueurs de la
foule éclate de longs applaudissements
lorsque le cercueil de jean paul ii
pénètre dans la basilique saint-pierre à
1500 kilomètres de là le deuil est
universel l'émotion en mondovision
mais sans doute plus grande ici
qu'ailleurs car on pleure l'enfant du
pays
à wadowice et ils sont vingt milles
devant la basilique notre dame où jean
paul ii officiait comme enfant de choeur
c'est le monde entier qui est un genou à
terre dit cette femme ce qui se passe
c'est terrible vraiment terrible jean
paul ii se disait fils de la nation
polonaise
c'est un père que l'on célèbre
aujourd'hui devant la maison où il est
né un tapis de bougies comme un lieu de
pèlerinage avec fidel et icône
la pologne est orpheline et s'interroge
sur son avenir il faut vivre dit
celui-ci l'avenir on verra avec le temps
qui sera le nouveau pari
ce qui est sûr ajoute ce père de famille
c'est que tous ici revoir plus fort en
dieu le temps des funérailles et même au
delà toute la pologne s'est figé
magasins fermés rues désertes mais
toujours s'éveiller l'intense est
immense
hier soir à cracovie ils étaient un
million avec un million de bougies levés
vers le ciel à 21h37 l'heure précise de
la banque en une semaine ce moment est
devenu dans le pays une minute sainte
ce pape à transformer l'église
catholique la pologne le monde disait un
ancien dissident
jean paul ii est déjà considéré ici
comme un saint avant une canonisation
que beaucoup de monde à rome on l'a dit
les fidèles étaient réunis place
saint-pierre pour les plus chanceux
d'autres étaient rassemblés devant des
écrans géants au total amiante sidel 10
des services de sécurité ont assisté aux
obsèques choses vues à l'intérieur de
cette foule qui avait été canalisé
protégé par des milliers de militaires
et policiers
isabelle steiss emmanuel bex
exceptionnellement les soeurs ont mis de
côté leur traditionnel retenu au petit
matin elle traverse sans courant la
place saint pierre pour être au plus
prêt de la salle et mono derniers
préparatifs derniers moments de calme
avant d'accueillir la foule
s'impatiente au loin premier malaise
tout le secteur du vatican est bloqué
que je crois que leo les voitures des
chefs départ sur le parcours des
personnalités mille tireurs d'élite ont
pris position
quarante mille policiers carabiniers et
militaires sont déployés autour du
vatican jamais rome n'a réuni en un jour
autant de chefs religieux de
personnalités du monde entier
tous rendent hommage au pape rassembleur
bien qu'il soit catholique est
représentée en échec cette église il a
réussi à composer le film et le renne le
respect à à la terre entière
la plupart des évêques et cardinaux qui
assistent à la cérémonie ont été nommés
par jean paul ii parmi eux cinq
cardinaux français dont l'émotion se
mettent à la ferveur populaire pour des
gens comme moi qui est qui et renwez
kessé des responsabilités nationales
depuis 27 ans en même temps que lui
c'est toute une page et de sa vie et de
notre société et de ma vie qui se tourne
aujourd'hui on repart la tête
on vient là pour le prochain ils
avancent maintenant vers l'avenir
les fidèles s'éloigne comme ils sont
venus dans le calme et la prière venus
des quatre coins de france plusieurs
centaines de français se sont retrouvés
dès l'aube près du centre ville
installées autour du grand stade en tic
le circo massimo même s'il n'était pas
place saint pierre ils ont ressenti avec
la même ferveur et la même intensité ces
funérailles
philippe visseyrias remet un peu de
piment
aymeric est intarissable lorsqu'il
s'agit d'expliquer la liturgie arrivé
hier soir à rome ce membre d'une
communauté catholique est venu
accompagné d'adolescents originaires des
quartiers nord de marseille comme dans
d'autres ils n'ont pu accéder à la place
saint-pierre et ont dû se contenter des
deux écrans géants du cirque maxime
une esplanade hérité de la romantique
trente mille pèlerins parmi eux 700
français
ce qui m'impressionne c'est c'est toute
cette jeunesse qui vibre pour pour son
pape quoi là je trouve pour un
enterrement une joie extraordinaire
pendant la cérémonie un confessionnal en
plein air est improvisé derrière l'écran
on peut aussi communier il règne sur le
cirque maxime
une atmosphère qui rappelle les journées
mondiales de la jeunesse créé par jean
paul ii à la fin de la retransmission
les pèlerins français se regroupent avec
le sentiment d'avoir vécu les obsèques
du pape aussi intensément que s'il était
allé place saint pierre
donc tout est calme
l'axé qui comptait collecte de venir ici
aymeric lui pense déjà au successeur de
jean paul ii maintenant ils n'offrir se
tourner vers vers les cardinaux que
qu'ils écoutent l'esprit saint et que
comme dit un jeune hier soir à la
musique de saint-jean-de-latran kuzeo un
autre parent qui nous emmène qui nous
amène encore plus loin dans l'amour du
christ et dans l'amour des hommes ils
repartent vers la france plus de 1500
kilomètres en train les attendent
mais ils auront vécu cette journée
historique au plus près ceci nous ramène
à paris avec et cette messe en début de
soirée à notre dame une messe
concélébrée par l'abbé pierre
sur les bancs de la cathédrale une foule
de fidèles qui comme ce matin se sont
recueillis lors des funérailles de jean
paul ii en direct les télévisions du
monde entier ont retransmis la totalité
de ses funérailles planétaire un
événement d'une dimension inégalée avec
ces rassemblements à manille d'abord aux
philippines c'est le plus grand pays
catholique d'asie
des centaines de fidèles en larmes
souvent vous l'avez vue est en prières
qui se sont retrouvés là où jean paul ii
avait célébré la messe en 1995 lors des
jmj partant à présent pour le brésil ou
dans les favelas ce l'événement n'avait
pas tout à fait le même retentissement
comme l'illustrent ce prêtre qui même
pour la circonstance estime que des
pauvres sont trop souvent laissées de
côté par l'église malgré les
déclarations et les bonnes intentions du
vatican un salvateur de bahia reportage
de nos envoyés spéciaux bertrand coq et
yann moix
le jour se lève à peine sur la favela
mata escura tandis qu'à rome débutent
les funérailles de jean paul ii
l'image arrive jusqu'ici mais le
décalage est trop grand et malgré la
présence du prêtre de la paroisse le
spectacle l'inspirent pas grand chose à
cette pauvre femme épuisée d'élever
seule ses six enfants
on est dans un monde unifié mais avec
des contrastes énormes
on n'est pas ici dans la palette part
qu'on n'est pas dans l'est les chambres
des cardinaux qui vont et léger ça c'est
d'être là bien quand elle pouvait passer
quelque chose ici avant des légères par
le père michel et belges depuis 23 ans
qu'il vit ici sont français c'est coloré
de brésiliens mais son verbe et mordant
avec l'église d'en haut
191 avec un don d'argent du pape jean
paul ii il a ouvert ce centre d'accueil
et de formation professionnelle pour les
jeunes des bidonvilles
le père michel partage une vision proche
de la théologie de la libération celle
d'une église au service des plus démunis
avant que d'être au service de
l'évangile évangéliser ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire annoncé la bonne nouvelle
qu'elle est la bonne nouvelle
quel contenu de cette bonne nouvelle
c'est voler la famille qu'on a visités
voilà la bonne nouvelle qu'on va donner
à cette femme à ses enfants
la bonne nouvelle pour ces jeunes qui
sont ici au centre jean paul ii on
préfère former des jeunes à des métiers
simple et immédiatement utile grâce
auquel ils sont pratiquement assurés de
gagner quelques euros par jour dans leur
quartier
c'est mon rêve affirme ce garçon et la
formatrice confirme 90% des jeunes qui
passent par le centre arrive à améliorer
leur situation
c'est modeste mais c'est concret plus
concret que les grandes déclarations
papales sur la pauvreté dont le père
michel n'hésite pas à relativiser la
portée ici dans la cité de salvador au
célèbre beaucoup de mais c'est beaucoup
mais quand ça continue cette cette
distance énorme entre les plus riches et
les plus pauvres alors il faut se
demander que ces déclarations ça sert à
quoi
du prochain compte if le père michel
comme nombre de prêtres des bidonvilles
attend qu'ils réforment l'église qu'ils
acceptent de la décentraliser et
d'adapter son message aux réalités
sociales en afrique d'aimer spéciales se
sont déroulés en république démocratique
du congo où cette journée était chômée
puis au kenya là aussi les obsèques
étaient retransmises en direct sur les
télévisions
comme le montre donc les images qui nous
viennent de nairobi et avant de clore ce
chapitre un dernier détour par home où
vous vous trouvez gérard griesbeck en
direct de la place saint pierre la pluie
semble utile à chasser les milliers de
pèlerins qui était au tour de la
belgique toute la journée
oui c'est vrai c'est la météo qui a
gagné finalement il pleut sur rome
depuis maintenant plusieurs heures et
donc petit à petit les pèlerins sont
partis alors cela dit toute la journée
après la messe sic sont quand même venus
ici en particulier les pèlerins qui
n'avaient pas pu suivre la messe
autrement que sur des écrans géants
autour de la basilique saint-pierre mais
pas sur la basilique
alors qu'il est beaucoup de tôles bus
sont partis déjà vers l'étranger et puis
on attend une centaine de trains dès ce
soir la gare de termini pour l'étranger
aussi
il faudra quand même
plus qu'une nuit pour pouvoir maintenant
évacuer ces centaines de milliers de
pèlerins qui ont afflué ces derniers
jours on pense peut-être un million ou
deux millions de personnes qui en tout
sont passés par rome depuis une semaine
merci j'ai raté ce bec dans l'actualité
de ce vendredi en egypte un groupe
islamiste jusqu'à présent inconnu a
revendiqué l'attentât au caire selon les
autorités hier à un vélomoteur piégée a
explosé dans le quartier des souks très
fréquentée par les touristes
dans le vieux caire un américain une
française ont été tuées trois autres
français sont blessés c'est le premier
attentat qui vise des occidentaux depuis
sept ans hamas ou là olivier rub robert
sur place des corps ensanglantés
jonchent le sol
la vidéo téléphone a été réalisée
quelques minutes après l'explosion
18 blessés dont trois touristes français
trois morts parmi eux le touriste
française décédée des suites de ses
blessures
quand la bombe a explosé la femme se
promenait avec son mari dans cette rue
bondée du vieux caire islamique
touristes et cairotes ont l'habitude de
venir faire ici leurs emplettes venu
voir parce que parce qu'on est un peu
choqués on voulait se rendre compte des
dégâts
c'est un endroit ya toujours beaucoup de
monde c'est aussi très touristique est
vrai que ya pas longtemps qui a pas eu
d'attentât et on ne sait pas du tout
dans cette partie là ça ça pourrait
avoir la bombe artisanale composée de
poudre et de clous explique les dégâts
matériels les gifs outre un américain et
la française décédée un troisième corps
non identifié pourrait être celui du
porteur de beaux on cherche encore des
bouts de chair nous explique le chef de
la police scientifique égyptienne
ce spécialiste des groupes terroristes
islamistes est venu faire son analyse
simple amateur et pas du tout un havre
d'un groupe et je me passais vous voulez
vous voyez ici il n'ya pas que des
traces donc je crois que individuel une
analyse qui rejoint celle des autorités
égyptiennes elle parle d'un acte
terroriste isolé
pour l'heure aucune revendication n'est
connue mais c'est un nouveau coup dur
pour l'egypte qui tire du tourisme sa
deuxième source de revenus les autorités
égyptiennes tant que ce soir de
minimiser l'importance de cet attentat
qui a non seulement touché des touristes
occidentaux mais aussi frappé au coeur
de la population égyptienne et c'est une
configuration inédite depuis des années
en échec le message de soutien à
florence aubenas hussein hanoun vont
être diffusées vendredi prochain sur 170
panneaux lumineux à paris est par
exemple sont invités à envoyer ses
messages en ligne ou par téléphone à
partir de lundi seront diffusés le 15
avril prochain marquant le centième jour
de détention de la journaliste de
libération et de son guide
je vous disais en titre le nombre de
morts sur les routes a augmenté le mois
dernier et ce pour la première fois
depuis plus d'un an l'augmentation de la
vitesse serait responsable de cette
rechute et ce malgré l'installation
massive de radars automatiques françois
jullien pieds-noirs venin guéret
personnes sur la route sauf ce radar
pied sur le frein à son approche à 70 km
heure puis on accélère c'est l'attitude
de beaucoup de français désormais
habitué aux radars fixes et non une fois
qu'on les a repérés mais vous
ralentissez avant et puis on reste
il est quelquefois chaque fois que
j'imprime un plan pour me déplacer et
d'oulémas d'artisans l'effet radar
s'essouffle et pourrait expliquer ces
mauvais chiffres mars 2004 349 tués sur
la route mars 2005
367 soit une augmentation de 5,2 pour
cent peut-être la peur du gendarme s'est
estompée un peu qu'il y a eu de
certaines libertés prises il ya eu des
contestations sur les radars par
certains élus rendez-nous un peu plus d
berthet et c est donc ça montre qu'on a
encore beaucoup de travail à faire plus
de travail et surtout trouver des moyens
de contrôle plus rusé que le radar fixe
bien trop visible est certain que nous
devons maintenir un fort aléa dans le
contrôle par un contrôle humain
approprié et également par des radars
mobiles sur le réseau secondaire
ni vu ni connu des gendarmes en civil
pour contrôler l'automobiliste d'autres
en voiture banalisée qui circulent
incognito des solutions plus discrète
qui permettront peut-être de faire
baisser le compteur de vitesse et celui
des morts l'attaqué d'un fourgon blindé
à aix en provence touche ce matin quatre
hommes fortement armés et cagoulés ont
fait main basse sur un butin dont on
ignore l'importance
ils ont ensuite pris la fuite à bord
d'une voiture des passantes était
témoigne ce braquage un des convoyeurs
auraient été touché par plusieurs coups
de crosse le procès pierrine journée
entière de réquisition tribunal
correctionnel de paris dix ans
d'emprisonnement réclamés contre charles
pieri et trois dont un avec sursis
contre jean guy talamoni l'un des élus
indépendantistes de l'île de nick
verdeilhan d'alicja
antonia les pousses de charles pieri une
décontraction un sourire qui ne vont pas
durer
son visage va s'assombrir les larmes
coulent et 10 ans le maximum est requis
contre son mari dans le box il sourit
ouvertement charles pieri au coeur d'un
système de malversations financières et
de raquettes dans le double but selon
l'accusation de se financer et de
préparer revendiqué les attentats
un univers de non droit et de passe
droit souligne le procureur dix ans des
réquisitions politique selon la défense
la feuille de route
elles avaient été fixées par le ministre
de l'intérieur il ya déjà plus de deux
ans et cette feuille de route finalement
elle a été respectée par le parquet du
tribunal de paris
on aa décidé à ce moment là monsieur
sarkozy a dit eh bien nous allons à capo
knees et monsieur thierry aujourd'hui
effectivement les voeux le souhait de
monsieur sarkozy ont été totalement
respecté par le procureur de paris jean
guy talamoni n'a pas fait le voyage à
paris ce que les procureurs ont peu
apprécié l'accusation d' extorsion de
fonds semblent fragiles contre l'élu
mais trois ans dont deux ferme et cinq
ans d'inéligibilité sont demandés
monsieur talamoni on lui reproche en fin
de compte son engagement politique et sa
proximité avec des gens qui sont
d'ailleurs ses amis ses amis politiques
je crois que ça suffit pas pour
reconstituer
et qualifie une infraction de condamner
pendant près de dix heures trois
procureurs se sont succédé s'accrochant
désespérément aux volumineux dossier
d'instruction pour énumérer les charges
car ici au procès prévenus et témoins
ont fait machine arrière
si la corse à une tradition orale
ironisait les magistrats ici la parole a
été confisqué les urgentistes en grève
depuis le début de la semaine un
mouvement très suivi malgré la réunion
qui a lieu au ministère de la santé ce
soir patrick peloux confirme que le
mouvement se poursuit aujourd'hui le
décret qui instaure une permanence des
soins en concertation entre les
urgentistes et des médecins libéraux a
été promulguée plus rapidement que prévu
l'occasion de nous intéresser à ce
système où l'on retrouve ces deux
catégories de médecins pour prendre en
charge jours et nuits et week-ends
compris les malades à laval isabelle
quant à virginie travers sur cet écran
le tableau de garde des médecins de
mayenne le président du conseil de
l'ordre examine et à ses troupes pour le
mois d'avril il reste encore des trous
les médecins volontaires ne sont pas
faciles à trouver
alors une expérience est en cours
diminuer le nombre de secteurs
géographiques de 34 à cette aventure
sept secteurs c'est bien évident qu'on
sera de gagner souvent donc on pourra se
reposer plus facilement donc on n'aura
plus volontaire une garde commence
habituellement à 20 heures et se termine
à 8 heures le lendemain en mayenne deux
tiers des médecins libéraux l'arrêt
taming fort
c'est le cas du docteur rondot il ya un
ou deux actes la nuit entre midi et
minuit à 8 heures et se j'estime en
queue
on pourrait se répartir la tâche et que
comme de toute façon il y a des médecins
des urgences ou du smur qui sont
éveillés la nuit
nous demandons que les fraises urgence
leur soit confiée au de l'administration
que les urgences qui prennent le relais
exemple avec cette mère d'un petit
garçon qui a de la fièvre
son médecin a arrêté sa garde à 23
heures on n'y a pas de médecin
on sait comme ça vaudra mieux prévoir
avant 23 heures c'est l'anti quoi nous
suivons donc comme il y avait pas de fin
ici ce ne sont pas les urgences qui sont
engorgés mais le samu depuis deux ans le
centre 15 gère tous les appels et leur
nombre a explosé
quatre fois plus et sans moyens humains
supplémentaires
et forcément la situation est de plus en
plus tendue preuve que la permanence des
soins n'est pas qu'une affaire de
volonté
c'est aussi une affaire d'argent janvier
à cette affaire d'escroquerie aux
assedic un système organisé ou de faux
bulletins de salaire permettait de
toucher les indemnités de chômage 17
personnes ont été interpellées en mars à
mulhouse et en moselle
huit autres cette semaine en haute
savoie christophe medard et jean-pierre
pasteur aux assedic du mulhouse
c'est du jamais vu il faut dire que
l'escroquerie était bien rodé prenez des
volontaires en quête d'argent facile
donnez leur des attestations d'employeur
et des feuilles de pays suisse falsifiés
inscrivez les aux assedic
grâce à un accord franco suisse il
touche chômage reste à reverser une
commission à l'organisateur de la fraude
le préjudice est colossal au total il
représente 500 mille euros de préjudice
qui se décomposant en deux cent mille
euros de préjudice déjà effectués et
pour le reste c'était si le dossier
avait continué encore la même façon des
adresses un peu trop similaire des
fautes d'orthographe
voilà ce qui a trahi ses faux chômeurs à
mulhouse
dix-sept personnes sont mises en examen
pour escroquerie en bande organisée
la tête du réseau un homme de 30 ans
aujourd'hui crew et travailler avec des
rabatteurs grosso modo on peut dire
qu'effectivement c'est un peu le bouche
à oreille on allait on allait recruter
les copains dont on pensait qu'il
pouvait rentrer dans le système de la
fraude généralisée
l' enquête n'est pas terminée d'autres
personnes devraient être mises en examen
dans les prochains jours car le réseau
s'étend sur toute la france les pêcheurs
continuent leurs bleus plus des ports de
méditerranée notamment à sète où ils
réclament comme ailleurs une baisse du
prix du gazole les pêcheurs qui demande
au bout
en nommant des mesures de soutien et les
eaux lamberton parce qu'elles pensent
cela fait vingt ans que paul broué
técher chaque jour il passe 15 heures en
mer pêchés notamment des sardines
jusqu'à présent lui et ses trois
matelots ans vivait plutôt bien mais le
prix du gazole dévore désormais le tiers
du produit de sa pêche c'est intenable
pour la romanée et 14 faits la parole en
solo reste pas d'iphone
on a du mal alors donné alors donné plus
de 1000 euros par mois si paul gros
blocs aujourd'hui le port de sète c'est
parce qu'il est en colère en octobre
dernier le gouvernement avait promis un
report de charges pour aider les
pêcheurs mais c'est est contraire au
droit européen nous a dit que ce n'est
pas incompatible
on va nous as pas notre problème on nous
a promis quelque chose qu'on a pu
commencer mercredi soir le blocus du
port de sète pose de graves problèmes
ainsi ce bateau a dû annuler sa liaison
pour le maroc
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
tire la sonnette d'alarmé
ils prennent un avantage le reste du
porte et ils prennent à d'autres
professionnels qui n'ont rien demandé
davantage et sont en train de les
détruire aussi ce soir le ministre de
l'agriculture se dit prêt à recevoir les
pêcheurs s'ils lèvent leur blocus
ils sont actuellement en train de
décider des suites de leur mouvement
et puis ce rectificatif dans l'enquêté
sur les détournements de subventions
profit de la fnsea dans notre journal de
20h hier nous indiquions que trois
ministres pourraient être poursuivis par
la justice contrairement à ce qui a été
dit le nom de l'ancien ministre de
l'économie jean arthuis ne figure pas
dans le dossier pour ceux qui font leur
déclaration d'impôt sur internet sachez
que vous avez un délai supplémentaire de
plusieurs jours victime de son succès
apparemment le système est saturé les
contribuables concernés doivent se
renseigner pour connaître les dates
limite qui varie selon les différentes
zones
les scènes de production du constructeur
automobile britannique rover sont à
l'arrêt jusqu'à nouvel ordre
l'entreprise est en faillite et s'est
placée sous administration judiciaire
une difficile journée pour les employés
et leurs familles vingt mille emplois
sont directement menacés yvan martin et
visages fermés ciel bas et sombre sale
temps pour over c'est officiel la firme
anglaise est en faillite dans son
naufrage
vingt mille emplois disparaîtraient je
suis inquiet très inquiet pour notre
avenir
pour mon avenir c'est fini c'est un choc
terrible
des milliers de personnes vont perdre
leur emploi coup dur dans un pays où
l'automobile est la principale industrie
désastreuse nouvelle pour tony blair en
pleine campagne électorale lui dit
encore y croire
nous sommes en contact avec le
gouvernement de pékin
le ministre des finances car nous
croyons qu'il est encore possible telle
usine intéresse des repreneurs chinois
la mini austin voiture emblématique de
la marque ou le range rover
n'appartiennent déjà plus à la fille de
reprise en rachat le dernier
constructeur 100% britannique s'est fait
vampirisé ces créations les plus
marquantes par bmw et ford résultats
rover depuis 1999 a vu ses ventes fondre
de moitié avec la débâcle de rover c'est
la fin d'un siècle d'histoire allant
gleizes des voitures de rêve
une saga automobile malmené depuis vingt
ans déjà
début 2000 c'est sur cet aéroport
militaire que rover devait stocker ces
milliers de véhicules invendus tableau
peu réjouissant pour un hypothétique
repreneur à monaco deux choses après le
décès du prince rainier la principauté
et fait face à cette nouvelle
préoccupante
le prince ernst august de hanovre époux
de caroline est en réanimation
son état est sérieux ciném'aude out
yasmina farber ernst august prince de
hanovre aux côtés de caroline de monaco
son épouse
sa dernière apparition publique s'était
ce 26 mars pendant la procession du
vendredi saint
alors que l'état du prince rainier
s'étaient déjà sérieusement aggravé
mardi soir l'absence du prince de
hanovre avait été remarqué son épouse
caroline et le prince albert assisté à
une messe en hommage au pape jean paul
ii
en la cathédrale de monaco mais pas lui
en fait ernst august de hanovre était
déjà à l'hôpital princesse grace peau
une affection aiguë du pancréas un état
très souvent liés à l'abus d'alcool
il nécessite une prise en charge
médicale permanente
ce sont les termes mêmes de ce
communiqué du palais princier décidément
les monégasques vivre au rythme des
bulletins de santé
deux jours après le décès de leur
souverain c'est un nouveau coup dur pour
eux c'est bien triste parce que les avez
pas besoin de ça on est déjà certes
restée comme ça
non
plaisir le prince quand même encore la
famille princière tous et ce serait très
grave processus
il offre pour la porter comme vous
les monégasques espère le rétablissement
rapide de l'époux de la princesse
caroline
pour qu'un nouveau malheur ne fera pas
la famille princière l'hospitalisation
d'ernest august de hanovre est source
d'inquiétude dans la principauté et qui
préparent les funérailles du prince
rainier ses funérailles sont fixés à
vendredi prochain mais dès dimanche les
monégasques pourront rendre un dernier
hommage à leur souverain défunt dont le
corps sera exposé au palais princier le
prince al aussitôt rentré de rome où il
assisté aux funérailles du pape se
prépare à épouser enfin demain camilla
parker-bowles le temps n'est pas de la
partie il y aura peu de célébrités au
mariage de charles les derniers
préparatifs d'une union qui ne suscite
pas un enthousiasme débordant en grande
bretagne ne remboursent y ait une
présence policière renforcée les accès
autour du château et de la mairie bloqué
à quelques heures du mariage de charles
et de camilla la petite ville de windsor
semble en état de siège
on est occupés on est très occupé même
mais c'est très excitant je pense que de
m'astreindre henri gourgeon il faut dire
qu'ici on a l'habitude des événements
royaux
les touristes sont plutôt amusés par les
dizaines de caméras et les centaines de
journalistes qui arpentent les rues et
puis comme toujours il ya les fans de la
royauté qui 24 ou 48 heures avant
l'événement prenne place pour être sûrs
de ne rien manquer dans ce pays ils ont
eu une très mauvaise publicité toute la
presse était contre eur alors j'ai
décidé de venir leur apporter mon
soutien et du soutien charles et camilla
en auront bien besoin après la mise en
cause de la légalité de leur mariage la
décision de la reine de ne pas assister
au mariage civil et le report pour cause
d'enterrement du pape
les journaux populaires expliqué ce
matin qu'il devait s'excuser pour leurs
péchés et leur vie dans le mensonge
on pourrait presque en rire en attendant
les gadgets commémorant le mariage se
vendent comme des petits pains les
premiers objets datait du 9 avril est
enfin arrivé windsor est donc fin prêt
pour ce mariage princier
hélas une nouvelle menace se profile
déjà le temps la météo annonce pour
demain
de la pluie du vent et peut-être même
quelques averses de neige
aux etats unis difficile semaine pour
michael jackson des témoignages
accablants dont celui d'un ancien
employé qui a fait l'effet d'une bombe
pascal golomer la journée de michael
jackson au tribunal commence toujours de
la même manière par un petit sourire et
un salut aux quelques fidèles
admirateurs mais aujourd'hui le coeur
n'y est pas vraiment la semaine fut
éprouvante les témoignages accablants
qu'il redoutait se sont accumulés
témoignage non pas sur la sphère pour
laquelle ils passent en procès mais sur
son attitude vis-à-vis d'autres jeunes
garçons qui l'avait invité par le passé
dans sa propriété
c'est un ancien garde du corps qui fut
le plus précis hier cet homme a vu
michael jackson en compagnie d'un garçon
âgés de 8 à 9 ans il les a vus à travers
une fenêtre ils étaient venus ils
s'embrassaient ce témoignage donne la
nausée
et c'est ce que recherche l'accusation
une réaction de dégoût parmi les jurés
l'avocat de michael jackson a aussitôt
rappelé que ce garde du corps avait été
en procès avec le chanteur il ya
quelques années
procès perdu d'ailleurs il vaudrait donc
aujourd'hui se venger je pense que la
crédibilité de ce témoin est
sérieusement nous indique mais ça sera
au jury d' le cid et le problème c'est
qu'il n'est pas le seul à témoigner il
vu cette femme de ménage qui surprit
d'autres attouchements et un jeune homme
qui lundi raconta comment michael
jackson avait voulu le caresser quand il
était enfant
une accumulation de récits qui présente
michael jackson comme un récidiviste
obsédé par les petits garçons on
comprend pourquoi son avocat s'était
opposé avec force à la présentation de
ces témoignages inoxydable la foire du
trône s'adapte à l'époque les amateurs
de sensations fortes vont s'en donner à
coeur joie
5 millions de visiteurs sur des manèges
de plus en plus fou et qui tourne de
plus en plus vite jean jacques dufour
jean nuit mena attachez vos ceintures
nous entrons dans une zone de
turbulences
les rotations des rotations à vous
décollez la pulpe du pont secouez moi ce
point et moi voilà ce que demandent les
jeunes et pas seulement les gars dans
les attractions vraiment forte
c'est surtout le plus le public féminin
et la chute libre éjection rotation
depuis quelques années les fabricants de
manège pont dans la surenchère il faut
de la sensation c'est la grosse
sensation même je dirais c'est plus la
sensation voile est de plus en plus fort
pour le moment la vie on reprend comme
un genre de lance-pierres les prendre et
les jeter et c'est fait monsieur vous
voyez maintenant les nouveaux manèges
comme le mac un oscar est leader c'est
les pays où elle lance pierre on montre
les gens allaient jacques c est je pense
que mana pourriez voir un peu comment
revoir les envoyer sur la lune allez
c'est cadeau
oui tu pensé quoi ils jouent ainsi
plaint alors le principe on monte dans
la boule et on éjecte à 45 mètres
d'hauteur est une puissance de cgg eu
que vous filmiez aussi c'est normal que
ce qui complique d'un petit souvenir les
gens de contraction bon
ce n'est qu'une façon très forte notre
manège
en avant du trône on verra pour
s'éclater à bruxelles franchement il
nous a trompés par le management ici les
accros des drones aline ont largement de
quoi se faire plaisir
quant aux autres eh bien ils se
réjouissent par procuration il y en a
même qui ont l'air de regretter leurs 20
ans tout à fait extraordinaire car
j'imagine les sensations que peuvent
leur procurer ces manèges et si je vous
incite comme vous ne montrez pas parmi
les engins monstrueux guy bop d'effrayer
les anciens jetons un oeil sur le triple
x c'est un bras puis les qui monte à 50
mètres de hauteur qui vous laisse
quelques instants tout là-haut en train
de réfléchir sur votre sort et qui vous
lâchent dans le vide après 230 km/heure
au ras du sol à la chasse est l'engin
coûte 400 mille euros c'est cher mais il
paraît que les jouets façon nasa ont la
couenne
c'est aberrant
salaire chaumont justement regarder le
booster sa propriétaire dit il bat tous
les records de vitesse
c'est vrai je voulais l'essayer toujours
plus haut toujours plus fort avec le
skyrider
coc
quand on les voit de passe est il bon
beat 1 environ 110 à 120 kilomètres
heure seulement les pois ça déménage
dans les manèges quand les gens ont
besoin de plus en plus d'adrénaline
courageux mais pas téméraire moi j'ai
testé ce manège un manège pour rappelle
mon enfance à moi une enfance où la
grande sensation c'était uniquement
motivé la queue du mickey c'est pas de
nouvelle neige à sensation à nos amis
restés dans l'ancien pour les petits les
petites sensations et oui à chaque âge
ses plaisirs aller rouler petit bolide
avant de refermer ce journal sachez que
ce tableau de picasso volés yann ans
dans un atelier de restauration du
centre pompidou a été retrouvé par la
police et remis au directeur du musée
s'agite de la nature morte à la
charlotte estimé à plus de deux millions
et demi d'euros
ses fans ce journal je remercie de votre
attention tout de suite le poireau de
valérie maurice puis la météo isabelle
martinez puis 20h55 pj comme moi
j'aurais plaisir de vous retrouver
demain dès 13 heures à partir de 14h
demain sachez qu'il y aura une édition
spéciale consacrée au mariage de charles
et de camilla édition spéciale présentée
par david pujadas et stéphane bern
excellente soirée sur france 2